The one piece manga just made it clear that
Admiral Kizaru is going to be a massive problem
for Luffy.
Because in this chapter we get to see a glimpse
of the Light man’s incredible powers as
he not only sends Luffy flying, but also easily
destroys this giant robot, and brushes aside
Jewelry Bonney like she is a bug.
On top of all that, the insane former warlord
Kuma is running wild in Mariejois, and in
his first MAJOR ACTION since the time skip,
the Fleet Admiral Akainu is coming to stop
him.
Which honestly I am just as excited about
this because it could mean that Kuma could
soon share revealing some of the World Governments
darkest secrets to the ONE MARINE who has
the power and ruthlessness to take out the
world nobles.
And if that wasn’t enough this chapter also
revealed a TRULY MIND-BLOWING secret about
the One Piece treasure.
That’s because Luffy’s LITERAL HEARTBEAT
appears to have awakened this gigantic ancient
robot, which could be the explanation for
why Roger couldn’t use what he found on
Laugh Tale, why Shanks stole the Nika devil
fruit, and why Shanks is now ready to go after
the One Piece.
But let’s kick things off with the most
heart-pounding action we’ve had in what
feels like many chapters.
That’s because Kizaru is clearly not holding
back AT ALL even though we continue to get
brief flashbacks about all the memories he
has with Dr. Vegapunk.
Which just makes him seem even more like a
pretty good dude who is friends with a lot
of these people like Sentomaru, Bonney, and
even Kuma.
And at this point I am a bit worried that
this whole situation is going to end with
a truly heartbreaking moment where Kizaru
kills his longtime friend.
Which I didn’t quite believe would actually
happen, but now that Oda is pulling at our
heartstrings with all of these wholesome moments,
it seems like he is really setting us up for
a tragic ending.
Either that or maybe Kizaru will realize that
he doesn’t just have to blindly follow orders
like a government slave.
Which is a pretty fitting parallel to Kuma
who was literally turned into a mindless government
slave, but more on him in just a moment.
Because first we have to talk about how TRULY
INCREDIBLE Kizaru’s powers are.
I mean it’s always been a bit disappointing
that he doesn’t exactly move as fast as
our real world light speed, but WOW this chapter
finally gave me some of the BREATHTAKING speed
I’ve always wanted from him.
Because when he zoomed away from Egghead only
to fly back in and ABSOLUTELY CRUSH Luffy,
my own eyes popped out of my head a bit.
Which makes this all the more impressive because
he did this to Snake Man Luffy, which is arguably
Luffy’s fastest form besides Gear 5.
However, I’m not buying that Kizaru is stronger
than Luffy yet, because we’ve seen many
times where a character looks super strong
for a chapter or two, only for them to get
completely wiped out a short time later.
Even the CP0 agent Lucci looked decent in
his fight against Luffy here on Egghead, but
then Luffy considered him no threat at all
just a short while later.
And this is especially true at the end of
the chapter when we see giant Gear 5 Luffy
reach down and grab Kizaru like he was some
child’s toy.
So this fight definitely has a way to go,
unless of course it gets interrupted by oh
I don’t know a giant ancient robot or something…
Okay, come on!
I have to be completely honest that when I
saw this thing waking up because of Luffy’s
Gear 5 heartbeat, my mind instantly went into
super theory overdrive mode.
We have Gear 5 Joy Boy.
The Drums of Liberation.
This giant elephant that can also hear the
heartbeat.
The Eternal Flame.
Roger.
Shanks.
The One Piece…
Whew there’s so much!
But let’s slow down and actually break down
what we know.
First of all, in chapter 1067 we were told
that this armored giant was made over nine
hundred years ago.
So clearly it is something from the technologically
advanced ancient kingdom.
Which makes me wonder, why exactly would it
wake up in response to Luffy’s heartbeat.
Well, unless this is just some sort of clever
trick, then the answer should clearly be that
it can hear the Drums of Liberation just like
the ancient elephant Zunesha could when Luffy
first awakened.
And now we obviously don’t know how this
is possible, but we should be able to assume
that somehow the Joy Boy who was alive during
the Void Century somehow made it so this thing
responded to his own heartbeat.
Which means now that Luffy also has that same
heartbeat when he enters Gear 5, this thing
is waking up to possibly fulfill its ancient
mission.
Unless of course it is waking up to attack
Luffy, which would be hilarious, but I highly
doubt it.
Though I can’t wait to see what crazy powers
it could have.
Vegapunk also told us that this thing attacked
Mariejois two hundred years ago but then ran
out of power before it could finish its job.
Which actually brings up some super interesting
questions of where it came from, are there
more of these things, and most importantly
how it awakened at all two hundred years ago.
Was there another Joy Boy around that time?
Or did it have some other powersource?
Speaking of power sources, this brings us
to another theory which actually got a lot
more evidence in this chapter, which is that
Luffy’s Gear 5 awakening might be the so-called
Eternal Flame that the Lilith version of Vegapunk
mentioned in chapter 1065.
And in case you don’t remember this was
first introduced during a discussion about
fuel sources and Lilith saying she would love
to make her very own sun for energy.
Do you see how this is connected yet?
So basically somehow Luffy’s Gear 5 awakening
will allow him to use his devil fruit to somehow
create his own energy.
I mean, his devil fruit is named after the
ancient figure Nika who is often referred
to as the Sun God.
So I’m thinking now that Luffy will literally
make his own sun which can power all of the
ancient technology.
Because keep in mind that the Vegapunks have
made a somewhat similar fuel source called
the Mother Flame, which was used to destroy
this entire island, but it is limited and
can only be made by Vegapunk on Egghead Island.
However, there is still a lot that we don’t
know, and I also wonder why this giant robot
didn’t wake up when Luffy was using Gear
5 during his earlier fight with Lucci, but
can you just imagine the possibility of Luffy
awakening a ton of ancient technology?
And speaking of that, this could also be one
of the first major clues for why Roger couldn’t
use whatever he found on Laugh Tale all those
years ago.
We know that his Vice-Captain Rayleigh said
they were too early to use what they found.
So perhaps they needed Joy Boy to awaken so
his heartbeat could awaken whatever is waiting
on that island.
This makes even more sense when you consider
that it was only after Shanks saw that Luffy
had awakened Gear 5 that he finally decided
to go after the one piece.
So maybe Roger told him or he somehow figured
out that he needed someone to awaken Luffy’s
devil fruit before the One Piece treasure
could actually be used.
Which sounds kinda like Shanks is just using
Luffy, but hey, there’s already plenty of
Evil Shanks theories out there.
Which brings us to the final world-shattering
part of the chapter where Kuma is going ABSOLUTELY
BERSERK in the Holy Land Mariejois.
And clearly he has some sort of mission here.
Whether he was given orders by the leader
of the Revolutionary Army, Dragon, or by Dr.
Vegapunk, we don’t really know.
Although it probably isn’t Dragon, since
he was so surprised in chapter 1067 when Kuma
left the Revolutionaries.
And Vegapunk also doesn’t seem like he would
order him to cause destruction, so maybe it
is his own last desire?
Which means we have to ask what his actual
purpose is here.
It doesn’t seem like a big enough goal just
to kill some Celestial Dragons, so if we’re
thinking bigger could it be that his true
goal is to expose some of the secrets hidden
in Mariejois?
Specifically, I am talking about the secret
ruler of the world, Imu, or if there is some
other National Treasure hidden deep within
the castle.
Maybe something like a giant straw hat.
And there is literally no better person for
this kind of mission than the man with the
OP devil fruit that can basically teleport
themself and other things.
So could this be the moment Imu is exposed?
And if it is, my goodness there is no perfect
person to actually witness this than the fleet
admiral Akainu himself.
And can we just give this man a round of applause?
He finally got to leave his desk for the first
time since the timeskip, so good job Akainu.
But all jokes aside, this man still packs
a devastating punch.
He easily melts parts of Kuma’s body, although
he could not stop Kuma from getting away.
But besides the fighting, we need to ask why
did Oda choose this moment to bring Akainu
out to play?
Because honestly, Akainu has always been one
of the most interesting characters in the
story.
Clearly he has a strong sense of justice,
even if it is super extreme, but we have to
ask what would he do if he learns that the
World Government he has always defended actually
turned out to just be a puppet all along?
Would he just keep following orders?
Or would he turn against the Celestial Dragons
and Imu?
I don’t really know, but there is no other
perfect time or situation for Akainu’s worldview
to be challenged.
Which means that very soon we could get the
simply MIND-BLOWING POSSIBILITY of Akainu
fighting against the world government.
And this is such an INSANE idea that I actually
made an entire video explaining how Akainu’s
journey would be if he was a pirate, which
you can watch right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.